to welcome everybody to the scooter
nation
I'm your host ethan klein aka the scoot
foolish scooters joined with me is my
lovely co-host and wife Eva Klein poopy
minimus scooter is foolish minimus
today's episode is sponsored by privacy
and ring and we come
first of all with great news last week
we had our epic scooter extravaganza
really we talked for close to an hour we
ordered the scooter live we did a poll
everybody a vast majority of people
voted 50% voted for the Gatsby yeah and
I thought at first it's just such a
stupid scooter but that's what makes it
great and you know Mike the guy we were
talking to who I wanted to take on a
scooter ride with me reached out and
he's like yo really funny show
everybody's been blowing our website up
but but seriously I work on Commission
so if you want to buy and I was like
Mike Big Mike I gotta get you that
commish the Dan's been chatting with Big
Mike actually here I've his email I
thought it was so funny which is a
family and not that made right cuz what
was his weight Big Mike do we actually
get his weight well what did he say that
he weighed he said enough oh you know he
just said okay
I have a feeling he's pretty big okay I
have a feeling you I don't think it's a
sound big it does sound big to me how do
you sound big there's like there's
something weighing down on the lung so
do I sound fat chunky but I'm not like
I'm not 600 pounds but anyway well we'll
have to find out Mike's true weight you
had a funny idea she's like actually
maybe you can now take Mike on a scooter
ride I think it's meant to be he's in
Florida though and I'm not oh isn't
Florida scooter that's the real
cybernation seriously well if we're
gonna make a scooter nation video we
should go to Florida
No oh my god but I do like the scooter
warehouse and tried them all out I'll
end up like you know those viral videos
were like all the scaffolding Falls and
that'll be minion so a lot of people
were impersonating like we have lots of
impersonators but this was the one it
was like Mike from at top mobility comm
I was like this is the real Mike not
talking about I'm sorry sorry that's
competitor yeah which one is it
progress yeah I wish to work that top
mobility because I'm a true friend of
that website but probably what's cooler
logo to be playing in progress yes
what does that mean progress like I'm
fat and I'm in mobile and I can't move
now I can move that's progress progress
there like there's nothing actually or
wrong with you
but you want to move and we can make it
happen that's progress literally that's
literally progress he said hello there
saw you bit last night that featured our
conversation about the double seated
scooter if I knew I was having such a
big audience that would have been
funnier Mike you were you were perfect
you're the light yeah I said I says to
Mike Mike you've lost all credibility
after he said he doesn't use a scooter
and he responded okay that's it that's
why you're Elijah thanks for making my
normally routine a mundane job pretty
exciting for once and if you're really
looking dure dure scooter we work on
Commission I'd be happy to hook you up
and help you out so Mike this one goes
out to you we ordered we officially
ordered with Mike here today we are
proud to announce we are the proud
owners of a Gatsby The Great Gatsby in
red luxury mobility scooter we spent
$3,500 on this ok you think we're
[ __ ] around here you think we're not
only himself this was a true democratic
vote and you guys chose this one because
we were actually leaning towards like
the classic looking one yes the boring
one but when I thought about it I goes
man if I'm thinking like iconic iconic
iconic r-e said
no Conakry when I'm thinking about Nick
do do when I'm thinking of like no but
not iconic but like iconography is that
a work that sounds weird what I'm trying
to say is like when you have the the
image of computer nation in your mind
typical scooter that's fine but what I'm
saying is the Gatsby is so unique it's
so luxurious it's so outrageous that
like imagine someone's drawing me
pavement or scooter niche and on the
front you have these big bold beautiful
letters the Gatsby I'm on a I'm on a
choo-choo train but exactly a mobility
scooter I mean the MA powerful yeah we
have a lot of great ideas though you go
you're saying our friends knew what
they're voting for they can think I
could I think so yeah but really the
choice wasn't ours
no but also Mike said that the Gatsby is
not good right he said he says it has a
customer satisfaction rating of 1.5 Mars
so my god to swayed us from getting it
and our eyes did wonder for a moment but
then I says this is democracy I says
look Mike the one one metric you guys
don't measure on your website is meme
meme meme ology yeah like meme rating
and that would have a perfect 10 if you
did
what's that separate meme economy meme
economy yeah right so I don't think he's
taking all considerations into play so I
respectfully disagree yeah with you Mike
on that one and frankly you have lost
all credibility at this point anyway so
there you have it and it's gonna arrive
in five days apparently
well five to ten looks like we'll see
clearly somebody's not driving it over
Bing how do you deliver that I have no
idea I said Dan who's bringing that to
us Howard there's some are they coming
and setting it up I mean what's
happening so we're just gonna show up I
think we're just gonna show up one day
to the office and the Gatsby is gonna be
waiting here and then some scooters are
on Amazon like you can buy a scooter on
Amazon
that's just crazy it's Amazon though
it'll probably like catch on fire
immediately when you get it I know it's
like a fake a Chinese fake yeah exactly
so there you have it I wonder if we need
to like wax and shine it cuz it looks so
polished in the picture think we'll see
for reference I mean you guys may not
know what we're talking about gatsby
luxury scooter I love the idea of it
being a luxury scooter but here this is
the Gatsby we're gonna for the proud
owner of a Gatsby I have some really
good ideas for it so you guys I think
we're gonna have a lot of fun with this
thing so if anyone says that we're not
in it for the meme you tell them we
spent $3,500 on this [ __ ] day one
point five stars satisfaction rating yep
capiche I think looks like those so I'm
saying you kind of got to keep it like
polished up you know that'll be a nice
job gonna keep the Gatsby shining well
I'm looking forward to that
until then we have been talking a lot of
[ __ ] about Arby's it's looks disgusting
it sounds disgusting everything about it
is a horrid we watched recently they
made a meat carrot I guess to taunt and
humiliate to belittle vegans and so we
thought okay Arby's let's take a shot at
this so this is our new segment called
advertised versus reality so we have got
a select items here for display and we
are gonna see well first of all that
already looks inedibly disgusting but
let's see is it does it look like this
or what and we're gonna taste it and
we're gonna tell you our B nation so
even once you come in here in is gonna
present this to us because he went this
morning and bought all this stuff and he
is an Arby's expert of sorts he even
admitted to me that him and his family
used to frequent frequently go to Arby's
is that right Ian now what was your
go-to when you want
RVs with your family that one right
there the classic beef and cheddar
this is cheddar it looks like nachos how
old like as a kid or it's an adult as a
kid I haven't been there and it's nice
what is this this is not cheddar cheese
we can compare it should we bust that
one open we got it so yeah let's go
classic let's just get right into it all
right so this is the first one so I've
got art we set up a hobby scam okay
thank you that we were oh my god this is
so repulsive okay so that's what it's
supposed to look like here's the RV camp
can you see it roast beef sandwiches
looks like a nasty badge bro like here's
the blips and then this is the that's
the bag they should to men cuz I mean
that's a lot of meat man they have the
meats where's the cheese though oh my
god they missed the center bro that's
not cheddar that's like [ __ ] nacho
cheese they did one dollop of nacho
cheese on the left side of the of the
sandwich you see that so let me describe
this to you these are the lips this is
the inside and then this is the cream
pie then is like dying I just heard
sounds like a bite on a cheese side even
I'm gonna get I already have diarrhea
olá bread the breads got a little stale
flavor do you uh would you like one you
gotta try it it's sweet I wasn't aware
that I was gonna try the boys sweet
diarrhea you steal okay you took one
bite no my question am I gonna take
another yeah well you want me to taste
it without cheese do you want to show
this so that what is this one that's
just the nod cheese one it's just very
sad looking at this [ __ ] I mean what
does this look like mega doodoo it does
it looks like a mega doodoo look at this
RVs you call this a foam this is ground
it looks like some weird Turkish like
intestines look how it like comes apart
okay I'm gonna take a bite and this is a
sad meal right here well you gotta try
it
I was trying to talk my way out of this
the roast beef it literally tastes like
the inside of a cows rectum I'm telling
you it's got a weird flavor I'm pretty
sure the Arby's it we did go to when I
was a kid there was one in town and I
think it closed down because they found
a rat in the kitchen oh you got closed
down for one rat well that was like they
got closed down it was way worse than
that it was they were cooking the rat
that was pressed I was eating all right
take a big bite and tell me what you
think but the cheese I'll tell you what
I I'll tell you what don't taste that
one the cheese masks it I feel like this
is the real experience yeah it totally
does take some this tasting like mustard
and yeah I'm gonna get that out of your
face there heat this so what you have is
shaved vagina liver there there's a girl
and it tastes like it hasn't been washed
in like a minute
lexan still I'm not yeah is there was
there a used tampon in that
make sure there's no tampon in that
before you buy them I feel like I'm
gonna feel refractor look at what's on
the line is this for $50,000 mmm that's
such a lame bite but it tastes like
yeah it's gamey fright like you know how
lamb is gamey it's got a gamey flavor
mm-hmm which you wouldn't expect you
know that's a course one so how would
you rate it against the you know
appearance first expectation god that
roast beef actually looks like I'm just
I mean not to nitpick you here are bees
but the color is completely different
look at this and look how thin this is
it's like literally like it will it's
like lighter than air
like I think it will float Megha doo doo
look how thin that no no I have no Alice
oh I got the whole experience for you I
mean look at this seriously
Ian you hungry I'm good on thank you
though okay next okay so this one is the
one us all laughs mmm ela had a good
laugh about this one you had it too ulis
she'll try it first but this one camera
so it's this one sorry I'm fine this is
the Buffalo slider so here's the Buffalo
slider on the sphere you show the
fixture so here's the you stamp on that
I thought it was in the roast beef
sandwich put it so they put it in bread
right okay then show the picture one
more time just to refresh there we go
okay all right here we go guys now let's
see this is exciting
okay so why do they make it look so
extended in that one like it they make
it pop out the sides like it actually
looks more reasonable here than in that
ad like others little cheese sauce
coming down the side and so this one
okay bright thank you so I mean the
sauce game is just out of control here I
mean look at this
mess so which one looks better to you
this one's not a problem though the
roast beef is absolutely no no doubt
gross the advertisement looks so foul
yeah it looks better in reality but look
at the steps off the side of the sauce
here you see that old nasty mmm I'll
save that pie for you you look no you
don't hate it I don't hate this one and
it looks better in reality what kind of
segment going to better say goodbye it
look I'm keeping it real but I didn't
know that I was gonna be trying all this
RVs not what you think was gonna happen
I guess I wasn't thinking I got the mom
brain I don't think any more such a
small bite it's kind of what you expect
it's not for me but it's not bad you
know mmm but I did want to show you guys
this cuz Ian had to pry it out it comes
in this and Ian had to pry it out the
bottom and I want to show you guys I
mean frankly a little period stain I
kinda had to like I had to really tug
Yad it out it was gloom out there
disgusting it's it's pretty I want to
recommend anyone eat that you wouldn't
know I mean what can you do it's not
really food dude well don't you already
know that when you're eating out it buds
what are we this is the one right below
it this is the chicken slider chicken
slider well why does everything look
like jizz like I feel like I'm at a lack
of words to describe this food but
everything looks like jizz no ezn gonna
try anything here I don't know I think
I'm good on this oh dude the cheese look
at this you want to see some [ __ ] some
magic sand David Blaine [ __ ] mega doodoo
you see this watch this
it doesn't come up that seems healthy
[Laughter]
alright feel like I don't need this top
bread it's a little stale to feel that
yeah well why the sauce that's like a
horsey sauce oh here ela you hungry this
fell off a stack that's the cheese yeah
the inside is just uh-huh
a disaster how is there a cube of cheese
here I don't know here there's more he
won't meet the gold Alfre oh yeah what's
the horsey sauce garbage also has a
thing called horsey sauce which I guess
is horseradish sauce why do you have to
call horses again I feel like it's
alluding to a horse load like if I was
for breeding horses I would be like get
me a horsey sauce there Louie without
you I agree with that I mean yeah it's
course we're at it was a horsey sauce
it's like I mean I don't I have no
interest in drinking a horse cup but
Zach isn't that gonna down one of these
Zach Zach wasn't back he was like second
loves an apparent that goes yellow of
course she does guys note standards at
all as a guy goes uh hand me one of
those horsey packets I want to drink it
I was like but so I asked him to to wait
so that we could actually wash with that
what that looks like but let me read the
ingredients okay because apparently it's
horseradish the ingredients an order is
soybean oil water high fructose corn
syrup distilled vinegar corn syrup
modified corn starch egg yolk
okay horseradish powder is like the one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleventh ingredient
that's horsey sauce they probably
couldn't legally call it horseradish
sauce yeah so they called it horsey Jews
sauce sack go ahead and slaughter
doesn't mention any jigs in their
ingredients doesn't mention what cheese
oh there's no cheers well they wouldn't
you don't have to label that actually
it's one of those ingredients off the
label I mean I don't know what calcium
disodium EDTA exactly
go ahead Zack we're all watching it's
your big moment open your mouth and show
us before you swallow it go I've got the
close-up to the camera we don't we got
appreciate your feet all right
slime another horses box but show us the
aftermath
do you I will use just squirt it all
over your face number two below it
waterfall it because we can't see what's
going on well we can't see we have to at
least see what I need the real horsey
shot I get close to the camera if you
can yeah higher higher higher higher
higher I can't even see it what a waste
of a horsey shot let's see it
oh my god bro no Ian did you grow up
doing that kind of stuff I did not that
was we passed on you some jiggling going
on you didn't take any horseshoe loads
no I did they should name it so much I
was allowed that wasn't mature rating
right there after what we just saw kind
of burned burned no way
chlamydia yeah I don't know
caught something okay well let me taste
some well let me put some horsey sauce
on it apparently how I say load are you
gonna shotgun it no I'm gonna put a
little horses up but here I'll waterfall
so you guys can see what it looks like
there it's like a bird [ __ ] on your
sandwich or horse or horse it's a horsey
load that doesn't look like I mean yeah
let's that's the law that's a big load
or it looks just like the cheese right
fine okay I gotta take the horse alone
[ __ ] doubt I put too much on now I'm
scared just remembered that Zach just
drinks - it does well it's not sitting
right
what are you feeling I got like some
gurgles going on oh no keep us updated
I will all right well I'm gonna take a
horse you biting some cheese so cheers
to everyone to your health and to my not
health to my dis health sure nice shoe
night mmm oh yeah bro oh it's really
strong huh oh no bro that's [ __ ] foul
it's like a man easy disgust [ __ ]
horse jizz is the only way to describe
that your turn yellow oh my god or love
the game I didn't out your turn
enjoy this looks so awful right I'm a
horsie Jesus I'd know there's a lot here
I know did you take such a buyout yes
okay completely okay what the [ __ ]
sake I was gonna try to oh yeah okay I
had it you first seal okay
that's so gross mm-hmm
describe what your experience you
there's like horseradish wood-plastic I
don't know okay
no imagine chasing 2pac is it up you
will I give you and you know it
no that's awful there's nothing good
about that and after knowing you shotgun
two of them no I think differently of
you man but ultimately to go back to the
sandwich I have to say they're
definitely out over selling the
freshness of the bun but they really
didn't dress it up in the Hat they're
like look it's a piece of fried chicken
yeah with a disgusting plastic cheese
and two pieces of bread so I guess
they're they're not far from your hourly
advertised all right we got two more oh
my god what is that so that's I think
all the way at the top I think this is
the Bourbon brisket oh it looks like I
got roadkill I'm not trying that one
either
if you want a hundred dollars a year or
1500 we didn't show that part yeah oh
the smell this thing is such a monster
first of all the bun is nice and soggy
you've got French what is it what is in
here bacon french fries roast beef
cheese Arby's sauce oh no it looks like
a heart attack it looks like they it
looks like somebody with a cowboy hat
named RB found some roadkill on the side
of the road and fried it up and this is
what I'm eating how come all their shits
like the same color you notice that like
the elder food is brown
just Brown they're like [ __ ] okay oh
that's the worst bake I've ever had it
literally turned to sawdust in my mouth
you need some horsey load on that no
it's so dry and powdery and sandy
powdery I mean for I'm telling you you
have to try this to believe it you see
sandy
it's sandy bro look like it's all
dehydrated so when your saliva hits it
you're like disintegrate it just turns
to ash mm-hmm is there any goodness in
it Zak you love it no it's sweet mm-hmm
it's a gamy
it's dusty what needs to happen to you
to eat this like like just that's just
another day in your life she's just
ordering baby this is this is a good old
lunch little boy
dude they didn't like just imagine this
restaurant they named it Arby's and Dan
do we have a picture of the logo by the
way we got a lot of [ __ ] I heard there's
no commenting on our Barbie shot I don't
see it oh there can can you make it
bigger can I talk about this logo
let me see we keep talking about horsey
sauce
why isn't there loves I'm gonna take a
full screen roll it up on your laptop oh
well that makes a whole lot of [ __ ]
sense doesn't it Arby's logo you tell me
right now when you're saying I was
saying that there's a lot of our beef
fence and I just heard that we were
upsetting a lot of people when I picked
up all this food is like 940 in the
morning it was poppin 9:40 a.m. why is
Arby's open look at this that is a use
that is a literally a used condom where
do you think all this horsey sauce comes
from this is their logo a dude named RB
this is what my by my house was lit up
with it looks like some like seedy Vegas
special yeah those guys spelled it out
but I mean seriously that's a used
condom but I I mean I can see like - all
the Arby's fans some of these weren't
like far from as advertised so if you're
into it you're gonna like it go ahead
what were you saying
what happened in your life that will
bring you to the Stanley yes at 9:40
a.m. exact clear okay okay I take a big
bite none of this none of this little
baby bites get in there like an RB bite
tell me about it
Sheila's speech and she's shaking her
head no what are they even like there's
a lot going on here and I don't think
what I experienced was just a whole mush
of brown
yeah I'm not experiencing that I don't
know there's no layers no it's very
distinct layers in that picture but I'm
all blended up and just like it's just
one cool yeah you said I'm saying about
it being sandy did you get that kind of
you know Guardian you taking a bite just
for the love of the game you just took a
bite hold on you just said goodbye to
that I skipped breakfast I'm kind of
another day all right I got a piece so
bad well wait till after the bit is over
mmm I won't go back from to that one no
second by to that it's so dry yeah yeah
I guess any Torcy sauce yeah it's like a
horsey load do we have to win more right
mm-hmm
I think we have one more but uh we're at
break time
so you're saying is it dirty right now
it's 30 right now yeah so let's just
finish up with these fries yeah you know
let's take a break we'll be back with
the fries you guys aren't gonna want to
miss this I guarantee I mean imagine how
foul this is gonna be all right we'll be
back I'm gonna go puke there's a lot of
times I'm on the internet and I want to
buy something with a card but let's face
it I don't want to give my card out to
everybody on the Internet
okay I got enough problems keeping my
privacy secret that's why privacy calm
/h three is the number one place to keep
your privacy in order let me tell you
about privacy what they do is they
connect right to your bank account and
make virtual cards for you that you can
use anywhere on the Internet like a
normal credit card and by the way just a
little tip privacy becomes less h3 you
get five dollars for free on your
virtual cart that's just five dollars
cash to buy anywhere you want what
here's how it works you can make a card
for anyone like let's say you know
Theodore he's on the tight budget I give
him $50 a year not much of an allowance
but hey I roll with iron fist you can
you can that's it and then this is the
credit card number he puts it anywhere
on the Internet and body being about a
boom he could buy anything he wants
anywhere you could go to a weird Chinese
spam site and buy a first suit and not
even worry about getting his cried
entity stolen like what happened uh you
know we bought that first suit for that
gag and then one of our one of our the
person who bought it on their card ended
up spending like a thousand dollars on
some dating site that's what I'm saying
and you got to protect yourself we can't
mess around with this you got to protect
yourself you can control your budget you
don't have to worry about your identity
being stolen or hacked
here's a ulis card that I made first
she's on one hundred-year bit she's got
a little more than Theodore because I
appreciate her dollars a year I gotta
keep it under I got to keep you under
tight wrap thank you my Big Daddy ethan
klein coming in hot and heavy with $575
single-use that means that once the
money's gone the card is dead so like
for example you don't want to get
overpaid annette you know how these
these reoccurring spending websites are
like oh wait pay me forever you put it
in and you never get over charge you
never get reoccurring payment for it
forever
so that's another you there's there's
there's a million great uses to it and
here's how it works it's so simple you
click the button you see the cards like
this is amazon obviously let's say let's
use Big Daddy's card this one's on me
Neela
use card bye - boom everything's in
ready to go name on card ethan klein
obviously and that's it
it works it works just like a card i
mean it's incredible you guys i i think
it's a great product privacy calm /h
three head on over there download the
extension sign up do your thing it's
free i thing money i mean what the heck
five dollars for frickin free head on
over quickly to privacy calm / HD for
five dollars for free you're gonna love
it
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know they're
smart video doorbell and cameras to
protect millions of people let's all be
honest I don't need this because I'm a
ring fan I love ring I don't feel safe
at home without ring I've got one in my
door I've got two on my the front of my
garage I got two on both sides of my
house I got one in the back guess what
somebody steps to my house I get a
motion notification they get blasted by
light and I could see him talk to him
hit an alarm and the video it tapes the
interaction when it senses motion it
throws it up to the cloud so let's say
you've got some mastermind criminal
coming to burglarize you oh let me cut
their lines uh I don't think so that's
already been blasted to the cloud and
it's there for me to see I got
everything I got your face and most
importantly I'll tell you what's most
important about ring you look what you
can get a video of someone robbing your
house and it still doesn't matter the
police are not gonna catch them what
matters is knowing when it's happening I
agree the motion detector that I get
from ring is uncompromising the best
security feature because once you hear
them you call the police and you're yeah
Eve exactly you get the notification I
could be chilling in Hawaii Oh what's up
police my house is being robbed I mean
that's the only way to protect your
house and if you're in the house that's
the best way to protect yourself too so
I mean I'm just saying ring it's the
best product I love this thing you've
also got the neighborhood thing so you
could see what your neighbors are up to
you could see what kind of suspicious
activity is going on in town its
connection with your neighbors and a
little radius of people who are honoring
I'm just saying it's the best product in
the game actually as a listener you have
a special offer on ring the Artic
starter kit available right now with a
video doorbell and motion-activated
floodlight cam the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home just
go to ring.com slash h3 that's ring.com
slash h3
welcome back everybody we have one final
item the cheesy bacon e curly fries
now it's looking pretty nice there I
like how the sauce is all like fluidy
not the case not the case that is just
uh
so they've three single mass yeah I mean
frankly I'm just honestly look sorry I
had to do it it's like a lava cake
it's a horsey load lava cake in the
middle there's just horsey jizz Megan
doodoo
you got it so it's a lava cake with
horsey load in the middle so let's see
how is it looking in the middle actually
I want to show you the top because what
they've done is they will look pre
loaded it with horsey jizz the cheese is
all plastic metallic look at this oh my
god oh my god I don't feel right my
stomach feels so bad from eating this
you away from the mic thank you damn
everyone thanks logo on the top left oh
my god mmm
here come get a close-up you up so here
this is a this is a this is a three-star
Michelin meal right here first you've
got the horsey jizz you got the fake
plastic cheese apparently it's cheddar
even though I'm sure it came from a pump
bacon that's been dehydrated shipped
from China and then they add water
yeah just sound great from your mouth
fries that were fried seven days ago all
came together for this perfect
three-star meal cheers everybody
oh I was pretty fun by the way I wanted
to ask you a thing oh good that's
dropping like a like a brick I wanted to
ask you how is your diet going today not
good but the good thing is when I eat a
meal like this
I'm almost certainly gonna be having
diarrhea or puking right you kind of go
down the collar you come I'm basically
just eating a laxative right now listen
you know how do you take this medicine
before you get a colonoscopy that like
cleans out your whole system that's
basically what Arby's is I feel like I
might puke like no joke
yeah well Zach are you so you stand it
you're spending no no oh that was then
all right so um well I've got a pile of
dog [ __ ] on my desk okay but I guess
let's continue on I should get rid of
that so thank you dan dan is gonna come
graciously now you mention okay this is
how you get rid of Arby's file yeah nice
very nice
thank you I love it
this camera is pretty handy yeah I know
I like you I like that being in your
hands all right does everyone want to
eat Arby's I'm afraid when I do these
said all these people are actually gonna
go at Arby's but my my goal is really
not yeah I think so much people are
still gonna go eat it I know I'm afraid
that's true well you you do it with what
you will let me ask you Zack you're the
RV's proponent are you gonna run out and
eat Arby's right now after this
experience no because there we this
crazy like the brisket one that's
supposed to have all these layers I was
like Zack go hit this up I thought he
would want it and he goes do I have to
eat this okay no of course not I just
figured you'd want it
no I'm I think I'm done ski here you
know ultimately Arby's I have to say
this for it you can put powdered sugar
over a piece of [ __ ] but ultimately it's
still a piece of [ __ ] what I would say
like all their sandwiches is all this
gay me disgusting dried out roast beef
you could put french fries on it you
could put horse jizz on it you could put
onion rings on it you can change the
bread but ultimately all you're doing is
putting powdered sugar on a pile of [ __ ]
right it's beautiful man I thought you
don't like it I like it what I expected
a war is honestly you know you can't say
that it's not for me I would never I
would never eat that little baby bite
I would never eat they're not you know
went over the audience that then like
well what do you think about this I
could see I felt I could see someone
into it you know what I mean is it
funnier and imaged where it says you can
put chocolate chips in a [ __ ] but it's
still [ __ ] alright I gotta
I thought powdered sugar was a strong
image because you cover it and you're
like oh what's this it's got powdered
sugar on it
yeah but chalk but something about
chocolate chips and a Duke it's funny as
well when I ordered it I remember now
that the woman was very forceful about
the horsey sauce way like I got the bag
she went do you want any condiments I'm
like I think
and she was like what and I was like no
we're fine and she was like are you wait
really you come on I'm gonna give you
some and I said and she went and ignored
me and grabbed a big hand for worse he
says well I have to say trying to get
rid of it Ian and her defense you should
have got horsey sauce kind of she was
right
yeah I totally forgot they had the
special kind I thought it's just like
ketchup so no horsey sauce boy so she
kind of said that woman saved she
poisoned us I feel I feel like this bit
would not have been as good without the
exact but save the show
a horsey load and the horse you look
yeah Jack's [ __ ] Zack
rest in peace ACK I thought you were
just making cuz it's called horsey sauce
that it sounded like jizz or whatever
but when he opened his mouth and it was
I think it was actually called horsey
sauce horse ah that's like the slang
that people call it but well I'm ready
to go home we have got more show to do
[ __ ] so I don't know I'm supposed to
talk about the Amazon fire now and I
just load Oh everyone in Brazil's like
our whole country's on fire I'm like I
just had horsey load so let's keep it in
perspective Brazil I do want to talk
about Brazil fires because this is a
this is important thing yeah this is
absolutely crucial that we understand
what's going on there three weeks now a
huge section of the Amazon force is on
fire The Guardian reported that 739
square kilometers during the 31st of May
was lost that's equivalent to two
football fields every minute that's
insane here's some pictures of what's
going on over there
wait this has been going on since May
over three weeks it says yeah thirty
last during the 31 days of May
huh that's confusing wait it's been
going on for a while I know that and
people are like why isn't why isn't we
talk I mean look at this the whole
[ __ ] that's insane look at the size
of this fire look is that not like that
whole Amazon rainforest I mean I know
like all this is rainforest but that is
remarkable this is a shot from space you
can see that ain't good
there it is the biggest rainforest on
the planet Earth looks like that
Hollywood Hills look at this that's lush
beautiful green forest yeah the biggest
rain forest provides 20% of the
auctioning in the entire world like how
are we going to cope with the loss of
this rainforest two football fields an
hour that's so crazy so this is close by
cities or cities all throughout Brazil
in the middle of the day are driving
with their headlights on because it's so
smoky in the country this is more people
talk about it because when you told me
about it which was like maybe a few days
ago I that was the first time I heard
about it I didn't see it anywhere so I
first heard about it and I think it was
a movement within Brazil to raise
awareness I saw like something about
save Amazonia and it was like number one
trending and it was about I think it was
a bunch of Brazilian people being like
hey we need the world to see this
because our the Amazon force is on fire
I don't know why I mean I don't know why
more people are talking about this it
affects all of us I feel like in the
last 24 hours its profile is raised
pretty significantly I'm seeing a lot to
talk about it now
see the fact that it's been going on for
a while and we're only now hearing about
it yeah is pretty telling there's more
about obviously a lot more to say
about what caused it how the
government's responding here's a video
at 2:00 p.m. on South in Sao Paulo 2
p.m. middle of the day is what it looks
like it's pitch black
its pitch black 2 p.m. imagine what it's
like to be in the and that's the yeah
okay
holy dude when I saw the rainforest is
on fire I'm like we are so [ __ ] cuz
not only is there more droughts there
now well here I've got a hold it up here
according to euronews it's unclear
whether the fires were caused by
agricultural activity or deforestation
both have accelerated rapidly under the
Brazilian President hare bolson ro both
Senate oh sorry for that pronunciation
but of senado who made opening the
Amazon Amazon the corporate exploitation
a key plank of his election campaign so
this guy basically ran and this is a
really tough philosophical question okay
Brazil is a I mean they have a strong
economy but they're like still
developing and their biggest natural
resource is the Amazon rainforest their
D logging it they're using the land for
agriculture previously they had
protected the land and this guy came in
saying I am going to open it up and
activate our economy so he deregulated
it and now all the farmers in
agriculturists are they they basically
light the fires on purpose to clear land
but the fires have just gotten out of
control and deforestation itself is
making the the forest less moist when
you reduce the size it's got like a
moisture profile and it dries it up
essentially and so it's more much more
prone to being burned I mean it
shouldn't be happening that the
rainforest is on fire at all
but deforestation and agricultural
activity okay people actually just
lighting fires to clear land is is why
this is going on due to the due to the
changes by the president but it's a it's
a interesting problem because like it
affects the whole globe that's everybody
it's the sovereignty of their country I
was thinking like we the UN developed
countries should pay them whatever it is
they make a year from harvesting land or
whatever the [ __ ] just we need to pay
them to not touch that [ __ ] forest
because not only are you providing less
oxygen but you're also the amount of co2
that's coming off of it from burning
forests is ridiculous it's accelerating
it's accelerating global warming I don't
know I think it needs human intervention
they cannot touch that [ __ ] forest
and obviously there are sovereign
countries we have to make it worth it
for them we have to bribe them in short
because obviously the only thing that
will talk is money yes because that's
why they're doing it so you have to
remove their incentive for wanting to
not I mean clearly they die I don't
think the people want to be living I can
only imagine when we had the fires here
we didn't leave the house and it was
nothing like this it was just kind of
like dust in the air yeah but one thing
you didn't want to be outside don't go
outside if you're you know sensitive are
of asthma
these [ __ ] can't see the Sun
it's so crazy wildfires in Amazon are
not natural events but are instead
caused by a combination of droughts
which is happening worse and worse from
climate change and human activities both
climate change and regional
deforestation are linked to increases in
the intensity and frequency of droughts
over the Amazon the Amazon force has
experienced three major droughts
considered they used to be
once-in-a-century events once every 100
years with some fluke of nature they
would get a drought now if they had
major droughts in 2005 2010 and both
2015 and 16 so the forest is drying out
it's getting less rain that's 100 years
happen five four times in the past 20
years Brazilian President well why don't
you go ahead and say this so I don't get
mega loaded yeah yeah yeah
airball so not all that I mean come on
that's probably terrible - I thought
yeah yeah Belson ro D d mega doodoo so
the Brazilian President de mega doodoo
blamed environmental groups this guy is
such a douche by the way this guy is a
[ __ ] nightmare
he goes maybe and I am NOT affirming it
all these NGO people because I think
there's a lot of nonprofit organizations
out there trying to trying to you know
take care of the yeah Loren's of the
earth as they call it he accused them of
carrying out some criminal actions to
draw attention against me against the
government of Brazil at the cost of
ruining of the rainforest that's why
they're dere dude it's crazy Brazil has
had more than 72,000 fire outbreaks so
far this year an 84% increase on the
same period of last year this is kind of
heartbreaking but I'll open it up just
to give you guys personal it's an
indigenous woman these mother [ __ ]
people that live in the forest she's
saying these [ __ ] came in and burned
down our reservation I want all the
media here to see it you know so sad
what a beautiful piece of nature and
no it's like dude it's the lung it's the
lungs of the earth I mean it's so
important to the planet it's so
important to the planet what about you
know we say that they have a sovereignty
but what about the indigenous people I
mean they were there in the forest
before anyone came it's also habitat for
like I don't know exactly the details
but like half of them the animal species
the most diverse and abundant place of
life on the planet the President on a
Facebook live broadcast man you know
Brazil's tits backwards when they
president is going Facebook live on
thirst can you imagine Facebook live the
president he on Thursday our president
would be on periscope I trim like Oh
Facebook live you never know on Thursday
that countries that give money to
preserve the Amazon rainforest do not do
it for charity but to interfere with our
sovereignty he said he does not want
charity groups helping to protect the
rainforest but you know okay yes we
genocided the Native Americans but at
least now we give them sovereignty over
the land they have these in digit of
tribes were there before the Portuguese
and Spanish came and took over Brazil
mm-hmm I feel like that for should have
its own sovereignty well the woman at
least in the translation she did mention
a reservation of some kind so well
they're burning it down yeah I mean
obviously I'm I guess they weren't
supposed to we haven't been fantastic
about respecting our natives
reservations either to be honest so well
that's true ma'am
yeah what am i yeah we kill them all we
definitely kill them all not great for
the first time the Brazilian president
acknowledged that farmers might be
involved in lighting fires in the region
well that's that's progress so on an
extremely terrifying note scientists are
warning that losing another fifth of
Brazil's Amazon will trigger the
feedback loop known as die back at which
the force begins to dry out and burn
in a cascading system of collapse beyond
the reach of any subsequent human
intervention Gregg's off yikes that felt
so bad reading yeah this is scary man
it's not good I feel like we're [ __ ] I
feel like the plant like seeing this now
that rainforests on fire I feel like
this is a critical moment for us as a
species and on top of that it seems like
there's nothing you can do about it what
can you do I think the UN and our
governments need to make quick action to
preserve that I think none of people
will anyone do anything I don't know
people are not taking climate change
seriously even our own government our
own president says it's a Chinese hoax
and we're all just arguing about it
until we're like the frog in the boiling
water you know you don't realize it's
boiling until you're already boiled it's
crazy
why are people taking climate change
seriously it is out of control
the rainforest is on fire guys in the
last half century about 1/5 of the
forests or 300,000 square miles has been
cut or burned in Brazil whose border
contains almost two-thirds of the entire
Amazon basin this is an area larger than
Texas area that's been burned is larger
than Texas yes the climate change would
Excel I mean the removal of the forests
and the burning of the forests would
accelerate climate change massively what
do you do about that you know
the rainforest has been in existence for
at least 55 million years it's not that
crazy makes sense yeah it makes sense to
me
but like I know it's terrifying what do
you do you know good question well I
mean what's the United States is usually
the one to take the lead on these kinds
of global initiatives but Trump doesn't
believe in global climate change I heave
it you know I mean I don't think he's
gonna say anything about it he's all
about sovereignty we'll say Brazil do
your thing
dude it's so short-sighted we are going
to [ __ ] die everyone's gonna die dude
the planet is getting you know the
hottest day of summer that just [ __ ]
sucks ass you know this is the hottest
year on record again mm-hmm and it's not
just hot it's gonna be hot here and LA
is gonna be uninhabitable Europe might
freeze over Amazon rain for the frame
forests will disappear global I mean the
the the sea line is gonna raise like 20
feet putting most coastal cities
underwater but yet it seems like almost
everybody doesn't [ __ ] care I mean at
what point I think that the Amazon force
being on fire could be a good catalyst
to make people care but every weeks
nobody Matt nobody to begin wait I
didn't hear about it for a while it
seems like until it's like in the last
day I'm starting to see it in the news
but you need a concerted global effort
right now that's the only thing in
change because they couldn't affect it
it seems so funny that like get about
Iran's nuclear on nuclear deal we need a
Brazilian don't [ __ ] cut down the
rainforests deal our generation everyone
loves making fun of our generation the
Millennials and it's like look what we
were born into mm-hmm we were left with
this dying planet unsustainable
disparity of wealth in which nobody can
afford to buy [ __ ] house we are now
we're facing the earth fire automation
is removing more more job just say that
Shake Shack this weekend there was all
you just order on the tablet there's
nobody there
they don't even don't even need to
communicate with it's just people in the
kitchen it was great alright and I'll
tell you what the customer well that's
what that's the truth though that's
right it was the great experience is
better I don't I don't want to talk to
anyone it was nice
Andrew yang is the only person who's
actually addressing future issues
nobody's even think like one none of the
main lis people running are not even
thinking about the biggest issues that
we need to be thinking about well to be
fair I mean just yesterday Bernie came
out with the giant climate change plan
or whatever sounds good yeah thank God
but I think automation I think is
equally as important but well I think
that obviously global warming is number
one because this we need to keep the
planet habitable yeah right the point
not I mean if it's a lot just imagine
you know what Theodore what [ __ ] he's
gonna bones already here I think it's
both what about our grandchildren I'm
not sure that this earth is gonna be
habitable for our grandchildren
that's crazy to think about it yeah let
me read this again scientists warned
that losing another fifth of the Brazil
Amazon will trigger the feedback loop
known as dieback which the force begins
to dry out and burns anis cascading
system collapse beyond the reach of any
subsequent human intervention it's a
Chinese folks also it's a I mean why are
these people so short-sighted leaders
our leaders are sociopaths they care
about power and glorifying themselves
they have no long sightedness they don't
give a [ __ ] because when they die and
they had their little power trip when
they're alive
to control the world they don't care
about what's left even for their own
kids yeah it's awful oh I'd rather you
[ __ ] rather eat an Arby's sandwich
then didn't read this [ __ ] again deal
with this you know what I'm saying I
feel even worse now than when I ate some
horsey load I guess who's gonna
transitive okay well we got lots of
horsey loads for you what happens when
the horses go extinct he's gonna provide
horsey loads then right zach is that
yeah I don't know man scary
we got spider-man this is a good one
spider-man this is an interesting story
now onto something really important
global warming [ __ ] spider-man was
kicked out of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
no no spider-man now this is interesting
healing I'm gonna tell you why
once iron man you know what we've all
seen the [ __ ] dis spoiler there's this
is you've lost the right to avoiding
spoilers and am I right in assuming that
yeah so with Iron Man dead and Captain
America retired spider-man was they
built him up at this as the kind of the
centerpiece of this new unit unfolding
universe and so it's a really
interesting story Tom Hollands
spider-man is out after negotiations
between Sony and Disney broke down sony
has owned the film rights to spider-man
since the late 90s which they originally
bought from Marvel for a mere 7 million
dollars by the time Marvel was not doing
well and was desperate for cash they
actually offered to sell the film rights
to all of their characters for about 50
million but Sony politely passed and
just took Spidey how's this for a good
investment you'e seven spider-man movies
so far have grossed 6.5 billion dollars
how's that for return
[Music]
what is that like a what kind of is that
like a thousand percent return something
yeah almost right yeah seven billion
Sony's like mmm-hmm
so the deal Disney made with Sony to get
spider-man back with Marvel was that
Sony would finance the films Disney
would produce them at Disney would
receive five percent of the gross it's a
little complicated Sony was making the
lion's share of the yeah so Sony was
paying putting up the money to produce
the movies and Disney would actually do
the you know their their creative game
would actually make it and then Sony
would get 95 percent of the profits and
Disney would only get five percent that
was the deal well that's pretty
heavy-duty and so what did so what in
exchange jay-z was able to borrow the
character and cap so even in Captain
America and Avengers infinity war they
got 95 percent no no no that was that's
what Disney got out of the deal is they
their movies like The Avengers movies
and and Captain America movie they got
to use because if Sony was making 95
percent of all those Spidey movies
that's [ __ ] crazy yet I mean these
most these two most recent ones you know
with the with the new kid so five
percent of the gross profits was still a
hundred million dollars for Disney so
nothing to scoff at
but obviously Disney is looking for some
juicier they're looking at the Billie's
they want that belly 100 million of
Disney's like yeah whatever it's like a
light tip that's like a when I you when
you like our delivering pizza and some
gives you a buck and you're like not
even worth my [ __ ] time that's a
hundred million to Disney basically
Disney was willing to take a relatively
small cut because they knew what a
massive crowd-pleaser would be to have
spider-man integrated into the Marvel
movies the time it was worth it to them
to ask you the money for the marketing
hype fan satisfaction
by having arguably Marvel's most popular
character as part of their film universe
the deal they struck ended with the most
recent live-action spider-man film far
from home that meant they went back to
the bargaining table
I see so their deal expired this time
Disney was asking for a much bigger cut
Disney wanted to split the profits 50/50
because they had built this huge
franchise and making ton of money you
know that I gotta say that doesn't sound
unreasonable if they were making 95%
before and Disney's making the films you
know yeah that's a ridiculous cut there
are mixed reports from industry insiders
on whether Disney outright refused this
or if they offer to compromise Sony
refusing write a compromise like 80 20
or 75 25 but the specifics are unknown
negotiations have apparently stalled for
now sony says they plan on moving
forward with the spider-man franchise
without Marvel's involvement that is so
weird
can they you even used home Holland and
Mike continued yeah they can yeah I mean
he's he's part of you know the whole
spider-man thing not necessarily part of
Disney's that's weird right like I mean
it's gonna they gonna be in a different
universe no yeah I don't know how they
make that make sense now
since this story broke out there has
been rumors that they have reached you
because of ice a you know an Instagram
post that Tom Holland oh is that what
you were basing it on yeah well there
are articles that it's a rumor right
this morning there seems to be some bugs
that maybe though posted a picture of
him with mr. stark we did it mr. stark
and you think that's alluding to the
fashion I mean not me people are
thinking their people are trying to read
into it [ __ ] 11 million bikes Jesus
Christ
11 million likes
[ __ ] me interesting well I had no doubt
that they would make a deal they're just
just he just wants a little taste you
know they wanna they want to wet their
lips a little bit here they like look
they've come on 100 million I want some
of that seven billion you feel me
yeah I'm googling around on the on the
trade so like deadline and variety and
none of them are reporting anything
about them reaching a deal so yeah it's
just a rumor from those pictures that's
all oh there's more pictures yeah go
more to the right I'm a sexual nature
Mart that's frankly I don't really I
don't think I think that's a reach
anybody that's being like oh I think
he's probably thinking like that's not
what I met at all he just meant when we
we hiked well and so yeah Disney has a
big their big Expo is happening right
now it just started mmm
so if they did reach a deal they'd be
announcing it you know what I mean like
they they want to let people know I
think rest assured they'll reach a deal
you know they'll get there though
they'll figure it out
this seems like a look dude we just
upped our Disney tickets to $200 for per
for just a one-day pass we've we've
we're stretching everything we're making
as much we don't know where to get more
revenue so we're gonna need more than
five percent you believe how much it
cost to go to Disneyland no it's crazy
can't believe it it's packed everyday
[ __ ] are digging deep to go to
Disney the next spider film is already
slated with Tom Holland how will they
handle this unknown as a current
iteration of the character is deeply
tied
his costume is an Ironman made techno
suit that's true his mentor and father
figure is Jon Favreau's character happy
the latest movie had him becoming
involved with shield the plot is sort of
dead in the water without any of these
elements remaining people are largely
mad at Sony well I think Disney makes
enough money give them 10% [ __ ] Disney
Disney some cruel evil Enterprise they
they just are exist solely just suck up
mom yeah when I left out to actually
when I wrote all this up I think I saw
that in addition to the 5% Disney also
got to keep all the merchandising oh it
is probably [ __ ] more money too yes
Sony's like come on yeah the thing is
Sony I mean what incentive do they
really have I mean they own spider-man
like well yeah yeah they made that great
and they also built up the franchise I
mean they invested and made these early
on spider-man movies and got people
interested by the way in superhero
movies at all more Marvel was even a
tweak on Disney's I huh am i right
that's true
did you think that Walt Disney would
think that his company would become like
the biggest blood-sucking money sucking
corporate entity that the history's ever
known
you could only hope isn't that crazy
like what didn't is become yeah it's
crazy the thing that like it was just
one person who started it yeah I always
think that about every big company you
just started making cartoons and now
they like own every media outlet in the
world hmm huh
that's like teddy fight yeah well I
wonder what teddy fresh will end up
owning half of the whole population like
uh that's like Teddy fresh owning like
every grocery store in the world
that's not really like that fresh bread
so there you have it it's crazy how this
actors like becomes so famous because
I'm when Tom Hollands Instagram page and
like it's insane
he's a fresh young face man he's a new
to the scene you know and now he's like
the biggest Muslim let me open it Tom
Holland Instagram Tom Holland on
Instagram 30 million followers yeah yeah
eight million homie in a car how do you
handle such a life change and like so
quickly if he loves it look at him
[ __ ] loves it oh wow this guy said go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] misspelled with an
eye and a middle finger emoji why why
just when you said that he loves me why
does Instagram shuffle choose to show me
of all comments yeah why that like dude
what are you doing yeah I am by the way
that's so funny when you spelt with a I
that's like 12 year olds are unearthed
exclusively why is this guy so angry not
fit it's fine we think of the dangle he
felt that his had to reveal the dangle
oh the air the air pods
well he said back to work so everyone's
excited I guess um there you have it the
dude's got fans well he's got like the
best media ever he's like on set with
all these famous actors and [ __ ] you
know what I mean I would have liked I
would have more likes if I actually did
anything interesting you know what I
mean well this one got four let's see
what is this
oh yeah he's acting I mean come on
that's yep that's way cooler than
anything I do so come home what's your
favorite spider-man everybody that's a
question for everybody
let me find what it's called cuz I'm
awful at like names I think I know you
know what it looks like Ian's like that
veins popping me go ahead Ian Joe Oh
spider-man 2 by far was that the one
where he fights uh the octopus guy dr.
octopus yes yeah that one was very good
is that like your favorite movie ever
you're very enthused about it it's up
there I think it's so good I loved every
moment that movie is that the one where
he kisses are upside down no that's
that's the first one yeah
did you Holland did you pop a woody when
that happened
did you were a young I did really like
that one the first two spider-man was
like I was like would Kirsten and Toby
Toby Toby is a good spider-man cuz he
really is nerdy and I think I personally
think Tom Hall is a little too like
handsome nerdy mm-hmm Toby was like
nerdy nerdy which is what spider-man is
supposed to be Tom Hollands like I'm a
nerdy guy but I'm also kind of a
supermodel right what Andrew Garfield
too was the same type of vibe the other
one right right right right I didn't see
those yeah no those are like looked over
completely yeah doesn't even exist how
about the new one the animated so the
animated I was gonna be my answer I
thought that the enter the spider-verse
yeah Wow incredible incredible movie to
check that out but I think the first two
spider-man with Toby was great now Ian I
mentioned I noticed you're not
mentioning the third one with venom
mm-hmm I still like it I've got on DVD
do you really like it one of the worst
movies I I'm telling you even as a child
a fan I mean my standards were low I saw
the first two I love them the third one
was was it was unbelievable I mean
watching him walk down the street like
all emo and confident as well know the
best is just so good so terrifying God
what if I I mean I'm sure I'll get claim
but I wonder if it's worth watching well
now obviously it's fair use so it's
funny it makes it it's just bad you're
defending the third one I have to side
with the enemas I love that movie
thank you no way you loved it loved it
spider-man 3 a venom let's see was let
me see pictures just show the picture of
emo and Toby that's enough that's what
all right you know Zack I've come back
around he became venom and he started
dressing like this bar is so good we
watch them there's a scene where he
walks down the street and he's all
confident like hitting on girls and [ __ ]
ok it's the back see the first the first
Toby spider-man was campy but that was
the good kind of kid it was great man
randy savage
wrestles with them and everything mmm
it's one of the greatest scenes ever
actually I can't won't go back and watch
those first tale yeah can we watch venom
I feel like we have to watch the venom
scenes you know what resist urge let's
resist resist I don't want to with
Disney on my ass I'll be Sony why'd you
send me you you want to click
yeah okay Oh what do you want what are
you trying to be good just a visual from
what we were talking about yeah that's
the thing oh this one oh yeah yeah
iconic so epic stuff talking about
movies i oh you could even see her nips
like I remember she was in like a West
huh mmm-hmm you could see her nips a
little bit dude was in the same look
what you sent me she was I noticed her
nips I don't I have no memory over her
nips
maybe it wasn't hit it cuz I'm gonna see
her nips and at you there they got a
horsey sauce this I got some horse I
mean look at that spicy sauce where
horsey load yeah I like it I like it
mmm now I'm going down the durst hole so
spider-man
I think they'll reach an announcement I
don't think anyone has to worry Disney's
just good they're gonna have to get
their [ __ ] together mmm the Sony's like
look I know you need me so come back
when you get your senses together I own
your ass
Disney I mean what were they gonna who's
gonna be the next spider-man if they
don't get spider yeah next time so
another character like that they're done
and they they [ __ ] up cuz they made
him the centerpiece of the whole
universe nuttin but spider-man rules
that's why and everyone loves Tom haulin
even though he's too handsome to play
spider-man I like him as an actor he's
too handsome play spider-man though I
hate when they always draft nerds other
but they're like secretly like models
it's like come on dude just put an ugly
kid in there can we just put some ugly
kids in there they're trying to make
money that's true get in there I can
watch it Toby wasn't ugly no but like he
was nerdy he was the supermodel probably
Toby was he's too old
in my opinion how ageism yeah
well for Peter Parker yes supposed to be
a high school student right no that's
true
Tom Holland is age-appropriate can't you
throw someone over some pimples and a
[ __ ] just a mess you know what I mean
like they had to CGI who's the go plays
captain more like you now we're trying
to sell this mm-hmm yeah when the first
spider-man came out Tobey Maguire was 27
that's classic
all right president that but about about
about about but this is me what I'm
thinking what's next
that yet that I got egged egged addicted
politicians and celebrities get trolled
by an obvious fake Instagram post I
don't know how people buy this [ __ ] I'm
in time again and like famous people too
like imagine thinking that posting this
is is legally binding I mean this is the
Sun like Judd Apatow like bro you've
been in the industry you know about
contracts and legality like how dumb are
you to think that posting this image on
Instagram is actually legally binding so
since Parrish a stupid explain what they
it's an image first of all do you have
the first iteration that said Instagram
so I'll give the the back you have the
the link right under that is just a
full-screen of it no the first one was
Instagram and then some that's why it's
all cropped out somebody put just oh
really
okay I guess I didn't see those so if
you read this it says it worse just
don't forget tomorrow starts the new and
you see how that dubby is cut out it's
like so obvious because somebody just
need to swear and wrote Instagram
interrupted over it the first person who
made it I think was doing it as a joke
maybe even the second person and they
spelled it Instagram can you guys look
for a picture yeah it was just like I an
STR EGR a.m. Instagram and so this
genius
so don't forget tomorrow starts the new
Instagram rule where they can use your
photos don't forget deadlines today it's
it's read it reads like us like an
Indian spammer that went to spam mail it
can be used in court cases in litigation
against you everything you've ever
posted becomes public from today no
punctuation even messages that I've been
deleted or the photos not allowed it
costs nothing for a simple copy and
paste better safe than sorry
channel 13 News talked about the change
in Instagram now this is my favorite
here instagrams and the pee and privacy
is bolded and judd apatow shared this
rick perry the secretary what is Burke
Perry's job
yeah Secretary of Energy Secretary of
Energy he's an official secretary
talking he shared this on Instagram you
guys know somebody point out the the
Energy Department is the Department of
the government that's in charge of the
nuclear arsenal
yeah so the dude is in charge of all the
[ __ ] nukes this is how it is yikes
Channel 13 News talked about the change
in instagrams private policy I do not
give Instagram its pasted in there and
the sizes different it's bolded for no
reason and it's not even centered I do
not get Instagram or any entities
associated with Instagram permission to
use my pictures informations message or
post both past and future with this
statement I give notice to Instagram it
is strictly forbidden to disclose copy
to spirit or take any other action
against me based on this profile and
know where its content the content of
this profile is private and confidential
information the violation of privacy can
be punished by law
newts ec-130e can someone look that
statute up yeah I just did it's it's
just like the International Criminal
Court
okay international was that gonna help
you note Instagram is now a public
entity all members must post a note like
this if you prefer you can copy and
paste this version if you do not publish
a statement at least once it will be
tactic tasks full tasks
Sulli allowing the use of your photos as
well as information containing in the
profile status updates Instagram does
not have my permission to share photos
or messages seems legit I mean um do you
have to be to share this I couldn't
believe that people were serious I
thought it was like a joke I'm just
trying to wrap my head around this is
first of all written like I mean it
looks so awful why would you just
visually there's also no explanation
there's no background why is the P
Bolden where is that P right here yeah
but they everyone's like just in case
alright dude yeah it's like you didn't
agree to all this [ __ ] in the terms and
service its Instagram bro of course they
already own your ass
idiot [ __ ] you know here's that here's a
list of notable people that fell for
this you're gonna like this Rick Perry
Secretary of Energy and former Texas
governor looks like a monkey here monkey
brain doesn't he little not really good
after that good what the [ __ ] did not
surprised I sure can share the [ __ ] out
there Julia Roberts she's a mom she
shared it on Facebook 20 times she sent
it to everyone she knows on Facebook Rob
Lowe
it's embarrassing I was surprised by all
these people it looks like such an awful
Photoshop just proves that I mean you
know you don't have to be smart to be
famous
Waka Flocka that doesn't surprise me he
goes he goes he read it he goes Walker
how's his response [ __ ]
what's that when oak's that's all he
said just our luck it's funny this old
lady Julia no more to him work yeah
she's well you know I've seen her face
oh good
this dude TI we're getting left
basically all of the range of people
we've got Rita Wilson I'm not sure if a
million with her and her pictures very
small but gonna tell me about her Rita
Wilson yeah she's been in a bunch of
stuff she was in 40 year old virgin
first time comes to mind she's the love
interest in that movie was Steve Carell
was this photo you could find no she's
just very small very short Martha
Stewart shared it from prison Oh
Zach's telling me that that isn't the
woman for 40 year old virgin
I guess all right good you don't know
she is I guess shaming me hey sure okay
and of course
Edmund rains older would who were all
well familiar with her to mega doodoo
but a lot of people got caught yeah no I
saw Bert Kreischer share it but no was
that comedian no but see he shared it
once and he said just in case that
sounds like and then he tried to play it
off like a joke and he Remo stood a joke
one I don't think so I think he got
caught I think he got caught I hate to
say it I think I saw it and I was
thinking it's probably a parody there
was a new iterations he said just in
case it was his caption he didn't and he
said maybe I'm missing a joke yeah but I
think Bert got da you want to get the
details you want to text him he deleted
it and then he posted a giant-ass
together it was a joke he wouldn't have
deleted that's what I'm saying he
deleted and reposted a new one on
Instagram yeah do you see one like I do
you know because I followed it in live I
was like oh a bird a bird okay how could
you get got and he shared it on twitter
Koon everyone
was goofin on him cuz I see one on
Instagram that says a joke
it says heads up everybody get in front
of this so it's like you serious no so
that one there saying I saw it on the
podcast I get something with him and Tom
goofing on the podcast but that's not
the first one hmm he changed the
description or reposted it bird bird
bird crap he's got a bird you know
birdbrain Bert print now we love Bert
but I mean I think he did it for real I
mean he's free to dispute the facts you
know did you know that the t100 is you
know the t100
from terminator he's like liquid metal
and he like run super fast after the
party I was in broke oh sorry sorry
that's a one times I think arm is the
t100 remember this seat wall that shit's
real that should actually destiny owns
in a restaurant in Albania have you did
you watch this clip it's unbelievable
these Spanish tourists went to this
restaurant in Albania
they ordered lunch it was delayed they
wanted to cancel it and leave the
restaurant the owner started threatening
the group with a knife chased them while
they were driving there's a video I'm
gonna show you guys in a sec during the
video there's another car with the
restaurants owner chasing them so well
without further ado we had to clean it
up a little bit because at one point
they're driving and he's brute strength
punching through their brute strength to
the one hand and punching through their
window with neither now he's stealing
back the glasses bear and his hand is
through the glasses peeling it back with
his bare hand
it's unbelievable this is all because
they wanted to leave the restaurant
because the food was taking so long to
cut it there because it starts to get a
little a little too violent for this
podcast his just his hands started to
bleed go seek it out though because the
whole video was [ __ ] crazy it wasn't
that it really wasn't that bad there was
a little blood so I was like I don't
want to risk it but he's he stays on the
for six minutes six minutes I was just
watching and disbelief because it makes
it look short from this he was on there
for six minutes unchain through it I've
never seen anyone punch like about the
windshield but then he stuck his hand
and peeled it out yeah and so they
stopped once to let him off and he
refuses so they drive off again and then
the second time after six minutes he
gets off and tries to get through the
door and they run I mean dude holy crap
they asked the owner to get off the hood
they stopped once and he refused the
cone and he lets go tries to open the
door and attack them it doesn't succeed
the restaurant owner got arrested by the
police soon after now there's actually
reviews on his disguise restaurant
dating back before this video obviously
a lot of people came here and swarmed
his restaurant when this video went
viral but for example these two reviews
or at least this one in the bottom is
from 2015 they says beware dangerous
place dangerous owner goes to this place
probably will be attacked by the owner
the first time we went at the beach the
owner got physical by punching a couple
who dared to sit both at the beach we're
both in the same Sun bed the boy got a
broken nose and was bleeding all over
the situation was resolved by the police
the second time the owner attacked
another couple why did you go back they
went back oh wait maybe it means there
were two incidents and that man is a
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
out the second time the owner attacked
another couple our friends even this
time the police arrived in time while
the owner was about to pull a gun on
them what all our friends who visited
this place had the same appalling
experience food is very bad very
expensive for what you get you're paying
for a five-star meal like paying at a
five-star hotel he sells the cultured
fish for wild fish for breakfast - I
guess he stayed here it's a hotel as
well for breakfast 2 eggs 2 cups milk
jam and coffee cost 30 euros
stay clear wow that's insane from 2015
so you know it's real now this one is
from that one's from from a weakness
also it's possibly fake but it
definitely fits the well I mean
considering he just you know stayed on
someone's hood punching the windshield
for six minutes so obviously he's been a
little touchy recently I think it could
be real a threat to your family's
well-being this place truly made me my
family feel not welcome you my wife
parents and in-laws Albanians walked
down the beach pathway and set camp
under umbrella waiting for a server to
come and bring a menu ask for money or
whatever but no the owner administrator
came yelling at us screams kicked my mom
it was my mom kicked her out of her
beach bed threw her towel and purse away
spit on me and hit my brother-in-law
with his knee my wife's side of the
family who were locals got really scared
I would have normally responded back but
not my at my home not not my home not my
rules there are wonderful places minutes
away I think that sounds real when I
think the the t100 video is just from a
couple days ago and this is a weekend so
this could have been I mean this guy's
been having a bad week I don't know well
you know how shut it down I went to the
restaurant page and they shut it down so
I think this one just squeaked by us as
legit how do you manage to own a
business with this behavior for so long
because the other one is from 2015 well
I was reading a lot of the rules and
they're all like this guy's scamming
people he's
acting like he's selling like ocean
bought fish but it's all farm raised
because it's on the beach and apparently
he's the cousin of like a politician or
something hmm
but I mean dude this is one of the
craziest things I have ever ever seen
have you ever been this angry before and
don't think so oh yeah I don't know
such six minutes this one on aware of
such levels dude punching a went a
window and feeling it back with your
hand over a meal and they're like
putting the foot up trying to keep him
out I mean I'd like to think I would
have slammed on the brakes and said I'm
rolling you know I'm on the brakes I
would have slammed on the brakes
cuz they were cruising for him like a
good three minutes and he was just on
the windshield and they're just driving
and they're going pretty fast they went
really far in the duration of the video
and by the time he got up they must have
been like three miles away from where he
started or more pocket out Ethan I need
a man spreading camera here man spray
that you got a camera now next time I'll
surprise you what can we what productive
thing can we give this guy to kill the
leader of the resistance movement
assented Amazon rainforest to keep
people from lighting fires I didn't even
know that was possible
don't do that filled back with their
bare hands not possible so Jack
but he actually punched through the
window and now he's holding on to like
the AC vent or something in the car I
mean it's totally outrageous this guy
would excel at fear ferrant Lee the the
translation is just them cursing at each
other
not much hey dude you owe me 50 bucks he
kicked that guy his mom yeah she that
[ __ ] was sitting on the beach she
shouldn't have been there
spit on one of them I feel like if you
spit on another person you should be
prepared to be murdered by them
spits such a weird thing to do that is
an act of hostility my dude and finally
we have something special planned the
ditch but yes of course always
now the beach buggy if you guys don't
recall as a song I feel like that we're
gonna get claimed for this ship maybe I
shouldn't even bother these claims are
out of control
VEVO something tells me this isn't VEVO
official three beats lied VEVO
we talked about this on Ethan in yellow
yeah this epic family they live in
Hawaii and they make music
it's the Son and the daughter on the
left and right and they make music
that's the dad obviously and that guess
he recruited some girls on the beach to
get involved there this is not a joke I
want you to know that it's not a joke
it's crazy that you can actually
restrict your kids into doing this
that's what surprised me every time
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
pretty epic little Jam I don't really
happy family or what I mean yes it is
you know I mean let's give the guy would
you ever make a music video with your
dad no that's why that's the thing that
surprised me the most about this but
they're super into it well we made
finally this - sorry
you think theatre will make a music
video with us with us yes yeah of course
you would they we made fun of this video
on Ethan Hill years years ago people
like to point out that in one of those
videos I did say that when we have a kid
I'm gonna make them dance like he's a
couple years off from there but I'm
gonna hold my promise and we will yeah
so the the gang is back for another hit
back from hiatus they've disappeared
wait this isn't it they're back are you
excited yeah
yeah should be everyone's grown up a
little bit you know it's pretty exciting
this just came out their last video was
killing me with three beats lied vivo
they disappeared for a year but that one
that we love is four years old so the
everyone's grown up the Sun the not are
the dads are all here all gang is back
four years later it's the reunion tour
the beach three Beach slide reunion tour
let's go it's pretty like a bohemian
they're like avant-garde so there you go
family magically Marco or what yeah this
is indie rock the family fill in with it
man I love it I have to say the
production is slightly better oh no oh
no she shot me with the love gun what a
powerful image unbelievable shot me with
a love gun
she shot me with a love gun somebody
down on the ground he was just like
kicking him in the face over and over
again that's best that's not a love gun
that's just you kicking a guy in the
face crazy edits
oh yeah he's just beating the hell out
of that guy man he's got green gloves
holy Sh is that Runk yeah that would run
for the kids I was wondering if this
isn't his new girlfriend that shot him
with the love gun and he's making her
participate in his music videos Oh No
it's not synced at all oh no oh no oh no
she shot me with the love gun three beat
Rock rocks our fans Rock pills
Wow there you have it folks
[Music]
well guys this is it man yeah I think
this is it
oh no this is heads up Zach races solo
[ __ ]
no come on be honest that's pretty fire
cracker Sun shower come on dude he
shredded speaker step that keep
spreading don't be a hater now he's a
connective anyone return
come on you see that hit that whammy bar
and everything I've done love done he
shot me with the love gun mega dudu love
gun for those reasons I'm out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well as you can tell by the sound
effects it is that time unfortunately
all the things do come to an end but
that doesn't mean we won't be here
Tuesday of next week because this is the
history podcast and you know our motto
we just don't quit you know we always
say no you say just don't quit and with
that I bid you all it is do a wonderful
weekend a blessed weekend with your
friends it is Friday - yes - is then
Friday I have not gotten used to it and
it drives me crazy that my brain is
still not used to it
what is wrong with me well every Tuesday
it's Friday right now and every Friday
think it's Tuesday I started to feel
that this week we're supposed to be over
it by now
[Music]
I love it
yeah I'm with you ela you got real
problems help by the way the house built
fell through with the realtor worse
nobody gets Commission everybody loses
there's no talk when the thought in fact
yeah Todd became on top sorry Zach did
you still get your 200 that no he didn't
pay up yet no did he because the deal
fell through he's withholding the
commitment yeah
are you serious he later the lady paid
for the lead if he couldn't close the de
lead that's on him the lead you should I
got another bonus I received no pain bro
you need to take that up with your dad
cuz he [ __ ] you he wined and dined and
then [ __ ] me
at least you want find you most people
won't even do that yeah that's it guys
have a wonderful weekend now I want to
ask all of our listeners whenever you
see a mobility scooter out on the street
do you guys feel like it's a scooter
like it's part of our nature yeah well
I've been feeling one of us when I see a
scooter now in the street it's like well
when I see it's good right I I keep a
distance look is it dangerous
well we may have the Gatsby next week
I'm so excited so that's something to
look forward to did you see I put a
screenshot of the fan email in our show
doc I've gotten like 170 emails about
scooters what are they what are they
saying you know they're like suggestions
or videos you know it's the typical
stuff it is just well kind of
anything interesting well yeah I mean a
lot of the scooter videos we've watched
came from fans but it's just it's it's
gotten to be a bit much
scooter mania can never be too much
dance well that's why easier so also a
little interesting information she's -
scooter - so far this office was also
our teddy fresh office so we would work
from here even though it's a tiny office
and now we are separating we're getting
a separate office for teddy fresh and
this is all connecting because I'm
thinking we're gonna remove all the
furniture and we can ride the scooter
obstacle so oh I didn't think about that
so it's really exciting just for that
purpose for applications for the scooter
I'm excited about I really I catch it we
just just that's it guys
that's all we got we'll see you next
week everybody
[Music]